hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast sex as a biological variable
in rodent models I am Brenda Kelly Kim
elaborate and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots for leading
scientific social networking site and
producer of educational web seminars for
more information please visit www have a
few important announcements before we
begin this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to get to as many of your
questions as we can you can enlarge the
slide window by clicking on the screen
icon in the lower right hand corner of
the slide window if you have any
technical problems mooing or hearing
this presentation please click on the
support button the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button
lower left would now like to introduce
today's speakers dr. Stephanie Murphy
dr. Murphy received her V MD and PhD
from the University of Pennsylvania she
then completed a postdoctoral fellowship
in the department of comparative
medicine at johns hopkins and is a
diplomat of the american college of
laboratory animal medicine after
completing her training dr. Murphy
joined the department of anesthesiology
and critical care medicine at Johns
Hopkins as an assistant professor in
2003 she joined the research faculty at
the oregon health and science university
or ohsu where she was engaged in
research focused on cellular and
molecular mechanisms underlying sex
differences in stroke and directed an
animal model score while at always hsu
dr. Murphy also served as the associate
center director of the translational
modeling program for the ohsu Research
Center gender based medicine and advised
researchers regarding sex as a
biological variable and experimental
studies using animal models dr. Murphy
is currently the director of the
division of comparative medicine in the
office of research infrastructure
programs program office within the
division program coordination planning
and strategic initiatives at NIH I will
now turn it over to dr. Murphy for the
presentation Thank You Brenda for that
kind introduction I'd like to thank the
organizers of the 2016 laboratory animal
science virtual conference for inviting
me to speak with you today about sex as
a biological variable and experimental
rodent models for much of my research
career I've been actively considering
sex as a biological variable in rodent
models of ischemic and other types of
brain injury as a laboratory animal
veterinarian I've also had to address
challenges create opportunities and
provide research support so that other
investigators could address sex as a
biological variable and their
experimental animal models this next
slide summarizes what I plan on
reviewing with you today I will start
off by defining the terms sex and gender
before discussing why one needs to pay
attention to sex as a biological
variable and biomedical research with
rodent models I will then describe some
common myths and urban legends about sex
of the biological variable and provide
some examples of when sex matters in
human diseases and experimental studies
with rodents lastly I will review some
general reproductive biology principles
experimental strategies investigative
techniques and available resources to be
aware of when contemplating sex as a
biological variable in rodent and other
animal models so before discussing why
we need to focus on this issue I need to
start off by emphasizing that sex and
gender are not the same thing but our
distinct terms that should not be used
interchangeably sex is considered to be
the biological results of the interplay
between sex chromosomes and gonadal
hormones it is a biological quality that
be applied to both animals and to humans
gender is a term that combines self and
societal perception of a person's sex it
is a socio-cultural process that is
generally applied to humans however
there has been some recent discussions
within the biomedical research community
as to whether some aspects of gender
could be applicable to animals and if
the definition of gender needs to be
expanded to include animals and included
here on this slide a table that further
demonstrates this dichotomy between
these two terms where sex has genetic
molecular cellular and physiological
aspects while gender encompasses
psychological environmental social and
cultural components I also want to make
a distinction here between sex dependent
and sex specific effects sex dependent
effects include things like weight
height basal metabolic rate body fat and
muscle mass things that are not as
easily manipulated in our rodent models
as such sex specific effects that
includes things like receptor responses
cyclical variation neurotransmitter
differences cytochrome enzyme changes
and sex hormone induced effects these
are elements that are a little more easy
for us to manipulate in our animal
models now why do we need to consider
sex of a biological variable
historically disease models have mainly
used either single sex or have not
clarified what the sex of the animals in
the study have been these practices were
based on the assumption that disease
mechanisms or treatment effects would be
the same for both sexes some of the
reasons why a single sex might be used
is that one sex may have a greater
sensitivity to the experimental
manipulations that are being done in
specific animal disease models commonly
investigators were proposed using only
male animals as a means of decreasing
experimental variability caused by
female hormone cycle
and I'm going to come back to this point
later on my talk when I talk about Miss
and urban legends on the flip side some
investigators proposed using only female
animals because they want to avoid any
internal aggression that can occur in
some species and strains that make
cohousing difficult but in some species
and strains females may be as aggressive
or even more aggressive than the males
over the past decade or so there has
been increasing recognition that disease
conditions disease mechanisms and
therapy responses may differ between
males and females this area has been of
considerable focus and back in the
beginning of the century the Institute
of Medicine actually focused on this
topic and issued a report on the
understanding of sex and gender
differences and their effects on health
and illness and the overarching
conclusion of this report is that sex
and gender appears to matter from the
womb to the tomb however reversing this
single sex approach in animal studies
has been slower to change than in
clinical studies and there are a couple
reasons for this unlike clinical studies
no legislative mandate exists requiring
inclusion of both sexes in animal
studies there have been concerns about
availability and cost of female versus
male animals investigators need to have
some basic understanding or knowledge of
reproductive biology in order to think
about sex as a biological variable in
your studies and lastly limited research
funding support and opportunities make
it difficult to increase the number of
animals in a study when considering sex
as a biological variable I'm going to
come back to this last point again a
little later in my talk when I talk
about miss and urban legends funding
organizations and journals are also
starting to pay attention to this issue
because it impacts on rigor
reproducibility and translational
relevance of research involving animal
models and you've heard some reference
to this and some of the other
presentations that have occurred through
this conference I list here for example
that NIH has released a notice last
summer in June about consideration of
sex as a biological variable and NIH
funded research I list here some of the
key points from that notice but the
bottom line is that NIH expects that sex
as a biological variable will be
factored into research designs analyses
in reporting in both vertebrate animal
and human studies and that a strong
justification based on the scientific
literature preliminary data or other
relevant considerations will be provided
in applications proposing to study only
one sex these updates have already gone
into effect for applications being
submitted to NIH for the January 25th
deadline and moving forward with future
applications so what are some of the
common perceived obstacles in
considering sex as a biological variable
in rodent models well earlier my
introduction I mentioned one common
belief held within the biomedical
research community that the estrous
cycle renders female rodents to be
intrinsically more variable than males
however there really isn't any empirical
and emphasis for this basis for this
belief I want to refer you to a
meta-analysis of 230 293 articles done
by prendergast and colleagues that
monitored behavioral morphological
physiological and molecular traits of
female and male mice what they found was
that randomly cycling female mice were
no more variable than males on any
particular trait and that's shown here
by this figure and the upper hand of the
slide what they also found was that the
variability was substantially greater in
males for several straits as is shown in
this lower video here furthermore they
found that group housing
actually increased rate variability by
about thirty seven percent in both sexes
so the takeaway here is that estrus
cycle may not need to be monitored when
utilizing female animals again it's
going to depend on the research question
that's being addressed another common
perceived obstacle is the premise that
cost and number of animals are
automatically doubled when considering
sex as a biological variable in rodent
studies however not every experiment
needs to incorporate sex as when
considering any experimental valuable
you need to do a careful literature
review first to see whether or not that
variable is going to be important in
your design and what others have seen
respective to that variable and setting
up these types of studies it may be
necessary if there's not much in the
literature to guide you to conduct small
pilot studies to directly examine
whether or not sex might influence the
experiment system being used and the
outcomes you are evaluating not all time
points or experimental groups need to be
covered when thinking about sex as a
biological variable in your experimental
design and you can use things such as
factorial design to optimize your animal
studies and reduce animal use when
you're looking at sex and other
variables in your experimental design
now I'd like to give you some examples
where sex and gender does matter when
talking about human diseases women
experience higher rates of adverse drug
reactions than men do stroke incidence
rates and men are greater than women
younger ages look more women die of
stroke each year nearly eighty percent
of people with autoimmune diseases are
women and approximately seventy to
seventy-five percent of patients with
multiple sclerosis are women but when
men have the disease they tend to have a
worse prognosis than women the incidence
of melanoma is higher in women but
mortality is higher in men and women
have half the mortality of men in
acute renal failure and I could go on
giving you more and more examples of
where sex and gender are important
depending on the area of interest this
next figure shows the results of a
recent analysis of journal articles
looking at the proportion of studies
using male and female animals the blue
bars represent studies using only males
the red bars those using only females
purple for those studies that use both
sexes and then gray for those that
didn't indicate the sex of the animals
used in their study and there's really
two striking findings here i want to
emphasize about this figure the first is
that these those studies that did report
sex male animals are predominantly being
used in many of these research areas
with sub exceptions being in
reproductive biology and immunology the
second really striking finding here is
that there are still research fields
such as general biology immunology and
neuroscience we're more than twenty five
percent of the studies did not report
the sex of the animal subjects and in
the case of general biology and analogy
more than fifty percent you and by not
reporting the sex of these animals it's
really making it much more challenging
for investigators to reproduce these
studies based on what's reported this
next slide further done further
underscores this female gap in the
experimental studies involving animals
the purple bars represent the percentage
of women in a population presenting with
the various diseases listed at the
bottom of the figure whereas the green
bars represent the percentage of studies
that used female mice and rats and
studies and what you can see is there is
a disconnect between the purple bars and
the green bars for many of these
diseases we are making assumptions and
outcome predictions on these various
diseases but we're misrepresenting the
populations that are being targeted
I'd now like to give you some examples
from my own previous field of research
stroke where biological sex has altered
outcomes and experimental rodent models
and what has mirrored what has been
observed clinically in the corresponding
human disease these slide this slide
depicts a commonly used rodent model of
stroke the middle cerebral artery
occlusion or MCO model in this model the
middle cerebral artery which is shown
here is occluded by passing a filament
up through the internal carotid the
common carotid artery to the internal
common carotid the circle was until it
reaches the point of origin of the
middle cerebral artery and this way we
can cause you their permanent or
temporary blockage of this artery and
study the outcomes this next slide
demonstrates how we evaluate infarct
injury in this model brains are
harvested and sliced into two millimeter
thick coronal sections and then they're
placed in a solution of 235 tri-phenyl
tetrazolium chloride or TTC and
incubated viable brain areas will appear
dark red as a result of reducing the TTC
by mitochondrial enzymes whereas injured
areas will appear white and in this
model we are interested in looking at
the cortex and at the caudate putamen
now that you have an understanding of
our models and the measured outcomes I
would like to present to you some data
from the stroke field looking at sex
differences in experimental stroke and
the study that you see before you is was
done by the al Qaeda lab in this study
Dr alkad subjected male female and oh
very optimized female rats to 2 hours of
middle cerebral occlusion followed by a
reperfusion period and then measured
infarct injury the white areas that I
showed you in the previous brain slices
to calculate a percent infarct volume in
the two brain regions the cerebral
cortex and the caudate putamen and what
you see here when you compare males
which are represented by the blue bars
two females rep
the green bars that the female animals
have a much decreased level of infarct
volume compared to the nails however
when you compare the ovariectomized
females to the intact males their level
of injury is comparable and these
studies would suggest that perhaps
female sex steroids are going to be
important to stroke outcomes there are
several well known risk factors for
stroke two of which are diabetes and
hypertension and what this slide
demonstrates that even in the presence
of these two well known risk factors
that can create even greater injury and
stroke outcomes we still see differences
in infarct volume between male and
female animals for example here in the
cortex you can see that female diabetic
animals have less in part by line
compared to the males and the same is
true for the hypertensive animals now
I've talked about sex as a biological
variable at the whole animal level this
really needs to be considered as well
when you're talking about the cellular
level and for many of our in vitro
models this is something to consider
because individual cells have their own
sex and I show here an example from dr.
menu a ruse work she was interested in
working at the row of astrocytes in the
response to stroke and she used primary
astrocyte cultures to look at various
mechanisms and outcomes and the effects
of different treatments what's
distinctive about her studies is that
instead of harvesting cells from ruled
collections of animals and neonatal
rodents she actually set up her cultures
based on whether or not she harvested
cells from male versus female neonatal
rats so she then exposed her male
astrocyte cultures and her female
astrocyte cultures to oxygen glucose
deprivation which is a way we can mimic
stroke in the dish and looked at cell
death outcomes and what she found was
that female astrocytes had significantly
less cell death than the male astrocytes
so we've been able to
actually showed similar findings and
other cell types where we've set up the
cell cultures based on sex and this
makes one think about some of the issues
people have had in reproducing culture
studies because people used mixed sex
cells and it's not always clear what the
ratio of male to female cells are and
you can see with the difference between
the two the different levels of male
versus female cells and mixed cultures
complete to a lot of variability in the
outcomes people would see in these types
of models another point I'd like to
emphasize with this next slide is this
idea of sex stratification and how it
could have impact on data interpretation
and I show here some work from Louise
McCullers lab where she was interested
in working at how two different agents
could affect outcomes in the middle
cerebral artery model and I'm not going
to go into the specifics of the drugs
and the mechanisms but the point I want
to make here is the difference in the
responses between males and females if
you look at vehicle-treated animals and
is one example here again you will see
that female animals have significantly
less infarct volume compared to the male
animals what's really interesting is the
response of each sex when they're given
the drug as being looked at in this
study in this case the female animals
actually have a worse outcome when
treated with this agent compared to the
male animals and this is true in both
examples if dr. mercola had used both
sexes but had poured the data she would
not have appreciated a difference
between her vehicle and her agent
treated animals for either one of these
cases and results like this might
suggest why drugs then too well in
preclinical studies which have used
predominantly young adult animals fail
in human clinical trials where they
start to see some of these adverse
outcomes in one sex versus the other it
also limits us in finding potential
treatments that might benefit one sex
versus the other if we pull our data and
we miss these types of observations
now at this point I'd like to talk a
little bit about reproductive biology
and how it might be used to refine
animal models for applications and
research on sex differences and disease
I mentioned earlier my talk that one of
the reasons put forward for using males
in some areas of studies was as a way to
reduce variability that might be due to
female hormone cycling however I want to
point out some aspects of male
reproductive physiology that could
potentially be a source of experimental
variability in studies in which outcomes
would be relevant to both sexes so I
give you a couple of examples some male
rodents are seasonal breeders and
undergo significant physiological
changes during the breeding season for
example chinchillas have since easel
variation in testes volume Siberian
hamsters can have fluctuations
seasonally relative to body weight as
well as testicular size and the South
African spine emails can have
fluctuations in testicular volume and
mass seminiferous to rule diameter
spermatogenesis and plasma testosterone
concentrations I want to also emphasize
that male sex steroids are not constant
and can fluctuate on a daily basis for
example testosterone levels are hiring
the morning in young men mature male
rats show a try model pattern over 24
hour period mice may also demonstrate a
diet or no rhythm of testosterone with a
pulse release pattern so the argument
that females have hormonal variability
you know it's not just the females males
can also show fluctuations in their
hormone levels another point I want to
make here is that mice male sex steroids
also decline throughout the middle years
of life in many individuals this state
is increasingly recognized as andropause
recent evidence emphasizes that the
neuro endocrine to aging and men becomes
quite significant by the fourth decade
of life
this is unlike the rapid and alert loss
of estrogen in women loss of
testosterone is gradual and then and can
be clinically subtle so again when we
talk about hormone fluctuations it's not
just limited to female animals it's also
relevant to male animals reproductive
senescence is another important aspect
to consider this phenomenon occurs in
both males and females and kit includes
all aspects of age-related reproductive
decline and roped pause and menopause
are just one aspect of reproductive
aging I know many people use andropause
menopause and reproductive senescence
interchangeably but really it's
andropause and menopause are just one
aspect of reproductive senescence and
this can vary quite widely between
individuals and it's referred to as the
climate Eric and human females now that
we've talked about male reproductive
cycles I want to briefly review female
reproductive cycles this is something
that may be more familiar to us versus
the males the estrous cycle is a
recurring physiological changes that are
induced by reproductive hormones and
females and the ranks and frequency of
these Astro cycles will vary depending
on the species for example mice and rats
are considered to be polyesters because
they have repeated cycles throughout the
year whereas animals such as hamsters
are seasonally polyesters where they may
have repeated cycles during specific
times of the years the two major
differences between the estrous cycle
rodents and the menstrual cycle of women
come down to the endometrium and the
sexual activity relative dando metrium
it is resorbed during the estrous cycle
but shed during the menstrual cycle if
conception does not curve and with
sexual activity females are sexually
active during one phase of the estrous
cycle and this is referred to as estrus
or heat but can occur at any time during
the menstrual cycle this next slide
summarizes the four stages of the
estrous cycle and the
that occur relative to the uterus ovary
and behavior and I'm not going to go
over this entire side but for example
when we look at estrus one sees the
greatest distension and thinning of the
epithelium we see maturation of the
ovarian follicles germ cell maturation
and ovulation and we see sexually
receptive behavior this is in contrast
to die Astra's we receive the resumption
of the endometrial lining we see corpora
lutea growth activity and then
regression at the end of the stage but
we don't see the central we have
receptivity this next slide just shows
the pattern of hormonal levels that
occur during the rat estrus cycle
relative to estrogen progesterone and
what you see here is that with estrogen
you see a peak and estrogen levels in
mid-to-late pro estrus and this peak and
estrogen precedes the peak of
progesterone that we see in late pro
Astra's and then there's a smaller
secondary peak of both hormones at the
end of net estrus beginning of die
Astra's now i'd like to spend the
remainder of my time discussing
experimental approaches and techniques
that could be part of an investigator's
toolbox when considering sex as a
biological variable in rodent models and
can be also part of the toolbox for
those of us that support research i'm
going to be talking about the
availability of female versus male and
reproductively senescent rodents sexing
of fetal and neonatal rodents the issue
of blinding studies relative to sex
staging and synchronizing female
reproductive cycles manipulation of sex
hormones some of the dietary
considerations need to think about an
arm animal models as well as sex and
anesthesia so first let's talk about the
availability of female versus male
rodents both males and females are
available from commercial vendors
however the cost may be variable between
the sexes depending on the species and
the string
the age of the animals you want to work
out and I want to make a full disclaimer
here I did a very very informal review
of four major vendors Charles River
laboratory Harlan Jack's taconic I went
to their websites and I did a brief cost
comparative analysis of age match
rodents to see what the general trends
and patterns were relative to cost and
what I found is that for Anina deficient
mice outbred mice and rats and inbred
mice and rats female animals were either
copper one cost or a little more
expensive than the males again depending
on what age you were looking at for
hamsters and guinea pigs male and
females had relatively comparable costs
across lifespan whereas gerbils the
female animals were either less
expensive or complement cost to the
nails and again this was just a very
informal look at what the cost
comparisons were relative to the
availability of reproductively senescent
rodents they are available through
vendors typically as retired readers or
there may be species and strain-specific
agent models that are available for
purchase more often than not these
animals are not sitting on the shelf and
if you're seriously interested in using
reproductively submissive animals you
might need to make special arrangements
for contracts to make sure that you have
a regular supply of these animals there
are some reproductively senescent
rodents available through resources
supported by NIH there are species and
strain-specific aging models that are
available through the National Institute
of Aging and the office of research
infrastructure program also supports
some resources that may make these
animals available to you some academic
institutions and research foundations
may have their own private colonies you
may have collaborators and colleagues
who may have aging animals that they
might be willing to share with you or
you may consider setting up your own
aging road and groups but if you do that
you need to make sure that you have
sufficient space time and money and that
you plan for normal attrition so for
example if you want a hundred
animals that are going to be 20 months
of age when you start your aging court
you may want to use twice that number in
order to make sure that over the time
interval that you're aging these animals
you will actually end up with the number
that you need now I mentioned before
that in some studies people were able to
set up sex cultures because they sext
neonatal rodents we are able to sex
fetal and neonatal rodents we've been
successful in sexting embryonic days 16
and 17 in rats and mice and we use many
of the same visual cues that we use in
the adult animals we look at Jenna dough
anal distance and we look for the
presence and absence of the testes and
the uterine horn in these animals and we
do a lot of training with our
technicians to make sure that they're
comfortable sexing fetal neonatal
rodents like many skills it just takes
practice while we're training people to
learn how to sex fetal and neonatal
rodents we validate their training by
actually doing PCR to confirm that they
correctly identified the sex of the
animals and we do this by either looking
for the presence or absence of the sry
gene which will be in male animals and
then we have a background gene that
would be present in both sexes and you
can see here it's very clear the pattern
between the male and female animals and
we when we use this PCR technique to
validate the training of our technicians
we find that our staff are about
ninety-eight percent or better at
identifying the appropriate sex that
means animals this type of backup PCR
can also be of use when you're doing
cultures if you'd like to double check
and make sure that the cultures that
you're using on the sex that you think
they are this can also be helpful if you
have to combine genotyping and doing
things like single pop culture you can
also confirm the sex of the animal now a
common question that comes up when i
talk about sex as a biological variable
is how do you blind for sex and again
several the presentations throughout the
conference
you've heard how important it is to
randomized into blind in your studies
and in order to blind for sex you really
have to take a team approach and I give
here an example from my own research
program where we planned out different
parts of the study so that we could
blind the eventual evaluation by sex we
started out with a technician who would
assign ID numbers to the animals and
then randomized animals to the various
treatment groups that the next person in
the chain would then take these animals
not knowing what they had been treated
with or how they've been manipulated and
doing additional experiments in our case
the middle cerebral artery occlusion
model they would collect the
physiological data and samples and then
those samples and physiological data
would be handed off to the next person
who would be blinded to both sexes and
to treatment and would do say for our
example in our case the infarct volume
analysis or would measure various
analytes in the blood or look at
different compounds in the tissue that
they again would be blinded to the
experimental manipulations and the sex
now for a lot of what we do in our lab
we would measure sex hormone levels
either to validate manipulations we've
done or to see how a hormone levels
correlate to our outcomes and since we
have a limited blood volume in rodents a
lot of times people could kind of guess
what sex we were measuring the hormone
levels for so we oftentimes could only
blind for experimental treatments but
the point is we did as much as we could
to blind as far as we could in the
process relative to our outcomes many
times the data would be analyzed and
then headed back to a third person who
would actually break out the data
relative to the code for the different
experimental groups so again you can be
creative and how you approach blinding
for sex depending on your model and the
questions that you're asking some other
skills or resources you might want to
keep in the back of your mind are ways
of staging the female reproductive
cycles this could be useful in
establishing time pregnancies for sex
specific neonatal and primary culture
models it may also reduce experimental
variability if you're using some early
stage females again for those few traits
where variability due to hormonal
cycling might be an issue how you stage
will be dependent on the species in the
strange strange you can discern the
different reproductive cycles either
using visual and behavioral signs
vaginal impedance vaginal cytology
steroid levels in the urine or the serum
or reproductive tract histology I'm
going to talk a little bit more about
some of these techniques vaginal
impedance is commonly used but there are
some limitations it will only often
limit detect a specific reproductive
cycle stage it may not tell you all the
different stages there is some
conflicting data in species rat and
guinea pig as to when peak impedance
occurs vaginal cytology is considered to
give a gold standard in terms of staging
animals relative to the different
reproductive cycle stages this can be
done either by collecting cells and
washer by swabbing each reproductive
cycle stage is characterized by specific
types and quantities of cells and but I
should caution you the length of the
reproductive cycle stage will vary among
Ronis and that will impact how
frequently you may have to sample in
order to narrow down the stage of
interest that you you want to work with
this next slide just shows some
representative vaginal cytology smears
just to give you an idea of what the
differences are between the different
stages for pro estrus it's characterized
by these small round nucleated
epithelial cells that predominate for
estrus it's characterized predominantly
by these irregularly shaped quantified
squamous cells for med estrus you
predominantly see these leukocytes and a
few cornified cells and then for
diesters you see predominantly
leukocytes and a few of these round
cells as you transition to pro esters
synchronizing female reproductive cycles
is another potential skill you could
apply to your research design why you
would synchronize basically for the same
reasons why you would potentially stage
the female reproductive cycles again
it's useful in establishing time
pregnancies for sex specific neonatal
and primary culture models and it may
reduce experimental variability of using
a synchronized email this can be done
naturally you can take advantage of the
fact that estrus synchrony can develop
in group housed female rats after three
to four ovarian cycles this is
comparable to the dormitory effect
that's been described in women we can
also take advantage of certain pheromone
effects for example the witan effect in
mice which results from the exposure of
female mice to a male or male urine and
this induces estrus in group house
females we can also again depending on
the species in the strain do this
manipulation artificially by using
either female sex steroids granite
releasing hormones and their agonist
good editor opens prostaglandins Andrea
lytic agents now depending on your
question you may actually want to
control hormone levels you may be asking
the question our sex story is going to
be important or are their innate
differences or they don't play a role
ovaries are the main source of female
sex steroids estrogen and progesterone
whereas testes are the main source of
male sex steroids or androgens I should
point out that the adrenal glands can
also produce some sex steroids but
predominantly gonads are a large source
of these sex steroids in order to
significantly lower and dodgin a sex
steroids level you may have to do either
gannett to me or combination connect the
N adrenalectomy and I should point out
that over react to nyan adrenalectomy
are considered to be major surgeries
because you're either penetrating a body
cavity in both cases or you're producing
substantial physiological impairment in
the case of adrenalectomy
with orchidectomy this can be either a
minor or a major surgery depending on
your surgical approach whether you're
doing an abdominal approach or school
approach however you have to justify
doing more than one major surgery if
you're combining gonna duck Tamizh with
other major surgical manipulations in
your experimental design so that's
something to keep in mind as you move
forward with setting up your experiments
if you want to look at hormone levels or
you want to control hormone levels not
only can you reduce the levels but you
can selectively add hormones back if you
want to see if it's estrogen versus
progesterone that might be important or
testosterone versus DHT and you're going
to have to be skilled in different ways
administering these hormones this can
include parenteral objections sub-q ipid
or IM injections you can also use
subcutaneous or IP implants involving
either osmotic pumps which I show here
silastic implants which are homemade
pumps are commercial implants your
choice of vehicle is going to be very
important if you're going to be
administering hormones to animals
hormones are fat soluble so if you want
to give an intravenous injection of
hormones you're going to have to look at
a vehicle like cyclodextrin which will
allow you to do that vegetable oils will
allow you to dissolve the hormones and
to be able to give sub-q and IP
injections but if you're going to be
measuring hormone levels your choice of
vehicle is going to be very important we
found out the hard way when we switched
from sesame oil to Cornell but that
actually caused confounders for the
hormone assays we were using and we were
getting all sorts of strange readings
and variables in her a say so when we
switch back to the sesame oil we
actually were better able to measure a
hormone levels you can also use
biodegradable matrices which is used in
some of these commercial implants
again if you're thinking about sex is a
biological variable you may want to
measure hormones this can be done in
your lap there are numerous kits
available many institutions have core or
core services available that will do the
measurements for you for the fee you may
have colleagues or collaborators who
could do the measurements for you and
there are vendors or commercial
laboratories who will do it for you send
out the samples and then the return
results to you you can look at hormone
levels both in the blood or urine there
are radial you know assay kits available
hplc methods and TLC methods you can use
we can also measure hormones in tissue
using hplc methods now I want to get to
this issue of dietary considerations and
this has more to do with estrogen and
estrogen sensitive models we know that
estrogen administration can alter
histological and functional outcomes in
experimental rodent models like stroke a
TBI Alzheimer's disease and eae
phytoestrogens which can be in the diet
exhibit both estrogenic and anti
estrogenic effects that are found in
most soy foods and many of our
commercial lab animal diets commonly soy
meal as a protein source there have been
studies reported that have shown effects
of dietary final estrogens on several
tissues and organs systems and we know
that dietary phytoestrogens could
potentially modulate physiological and
behavioral responses and estrogen
sensitive bruin models and I just again
want to emphasize this point I show here
three different rodent diets and the
total isoflavone labor level is shown
here and you can see that this diet has
two to three times dice of flavor levels
as this diet and this diet has about
twice so if you change diets or if
you're not paying attention to diet you
could be blurring out some of your
results or decreasing the sensitivity of
what you're looking at the last topic I
want to look at and discuss with you is
anesthesia
male and females respond differently to
anesthetics and the differences in an
aesthetic response could be either sex
dependent or sucks to spend specific
depending on the mechanism so amateur an
aesthetic choice in rodent models
looking at sex effects may be a
potential confounder and i give here an
example in diffused traumatic brain
injury study female rats were shown to
do better than male rats but the outcome
was very dependent on the type of
anesthesia the degree of the difference
they saw between the sexes dictated what
the background anesthetic was so what
they found that is that I so foreign was
protective and female so they saw the
greatest difference between the sexes
but pentobarbital was deleterious and so
they saw less of a difference between
males and females how things seem to
have the least impact on sex related
outcome in this study so you may need to
think about making adjustments in your
anesthetic protocols for sex again
depending on your research question and
i give here another example
pentobarbital male mice are more
sensitive to the anesthetic effects of
this drug than females so when rats were
given the same initial anesthetic dose
they found that males required more
supplementation to maintain clinically
comparative anesthetic deaths compared
to the females so again just another
factor to think about now in the last
few minutes of my talk I just want to
share with you a couple of resources
where you can get additional tools
techniques and information that can help
you in thinking about sex as a
biological variable when designing your
studies or if you're providing support
for studies where this is a factor and I
point here to the NIH office of research
and women's health I list the website
here they have some workshops that have
been video conferenced and are available
as webinars for you references they do
have some training materials and other
resources that may be useful to you
another great website that I frequently
go to is the gendered innovation
website they provide definitions for
different terms that are used in the
field they also provide some methodology
a checklist that they be helpful to you
and thinking about how you're setting up
your experiments and how you're
interpreting new data the other thing
that I like about this website is it
presents different case studies in
different fields of science and thinking
about these questions and where it may
be important and again and how you're
interpreting the data and then one last
website I'd like to point you to is the
organization for the study of sex
differences website they have an annual
meeting and oftentimes we'll put some of
the presentations from that meeting
there as well as some other resources
and training materials that might help
you in thinking about this question and
then lastly I want to share with you a
sex gender toolbox for experimental
scientist but I often refer to and I
think really helps us to to think about
this variable as you would any other
variable you want to develop your
knowledge of sex and gender issues do a
careful literature review just as you
would for any experimental variable that
you're thinking about in your design are
there known sex differences or gender
disparities for the phenomenon you're
going to be studying avoid using the
term sex and gender interchangeably in
your writing that way we will create
less confusion as to what it is we're
talking about discuss sex and gender
where appropriate always report the sex
of the cells tissues animals or subjects
you're using and I know this has been a
common message and some of the other
presentations that you participated in
during this conference if you're using
one sex justify why explain why and note
the limitations in your discussion and
always discuss the possible sex gender
implications of your findings you might
want to introduce a small intervention
do a small pilot studies to examine
whether or not some elements of sex and
gender may be important in your model
system add a hormone to one of your
cultures include male and females in
your key experimental groups
if you're working with both sexes
consider stratifying your data just to
see if anything interesting comes out of
that report what you find if you don't
see a sex difference that's just as
important to share as if you do we want
to raise the profile of sex and gender
issues and we look to each other to be
advocates for this as a reviewer you can
assure that applicants and authors
identify and justify the sex of the
materials used and make sure that the
terms sex and gender are used
appropriately ask questions of
colleagues and trainees have they
considered whether or not sex or gender
might be relevant to their work and in
closing I just want to emphasize again
sex and gender matters and many clinical
diseases and rodent models and again i
want to quote the institute of medicine
report it's important and it matters
from the world to the tomb sex and
gender effects are under studied and not
well understood this could open up some
new research directions and innovative
funding opportunities from several of us
that's how I initially got into this
field is we saw something unusual and we
investigated it and we realized it was a
sex-specific phenomenon also working at
sex and gender flex goes to the question
of reproducibility and translational
relevance if you don't know the sex of
the animal how are you going to
reproduce the study in the findings if
you don't know what the male to female
ratio is in a pool of analysis again how
are you going to replicate those
findings and how are you going to
continue on to apply to clinical
patients and then lastly I want to
emphasize that there are experimental
strategies and resources available to
all of you for considering sex as a
biological variable in rodent models so
with that I'm happy to take questions
now and if we don't have time for all
the questions I have my email address
here in case people want to follow up
with me with additional questions thank
you
thank you dr. Murphy for bringing us
that informative presentation before we
get started on the question and answer
period I would like to remind our
audience and attendees how they can
submit their questions so questions can
be submitted by typing them in the Q&A
box which can be found by clicking on
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window will try to
get to as many questions as we can I
just want to give our audience a few
minutes to type in their questions and
see what they have to ask you was really
very relevant information that we have
here today and I'm sure we'll be hearing
some questions from our audience I do
see a question dr. Murphy and attendee
asks in the over the term of your career
since you've been at this for so long
have you seen a shift in more
experiments and researchers looking at
gender whereas they didn't before
thank you for that question I've been
engaged and looking at sex as a
biological variable now for close to two
decades and I would have to say really
in the last five to seven years I've
seen more of a shift I used to be a
study section I would bring this
question about all the time and people
roll their eyes like oh there she goes
again she's talking about you know are
the male animals or the female animals
but more I'm finding more people are
starting to ask those questions as well
in some journals I'm seeing them require
better reporting the arrived guidelines
actually has made a big impact and
making sure that people report the sex
of the animals used in their studies
great we have another question an
attendee asked do you think genetic
rodent models such as for Huntington's
disease should be looked at in a gender
specific manner that's a great question
I'm going to have to speak and more
broader conceptual terms because i don't
have expertise with Huntington's disease
but I think it's always useful to to ask
ourselves how does this disease present
in both sexes what are their responses
and one thing I caution to a lot of
investigators is that even if you do a
pilot study to see if there is a
difference between males and females and
you don't see one there could still be
differences in the pathways each sex
uses in responding to an insult or in
developing a disease that could lead to
the same outcome but because they use
different pathways if you're trying to
target potential pathways for you
mentions you need to be aware of those
differences and I also want to make a
distinction here that considering sex as
a biological variable is not the same
thing as studying sex differences you
can consider sex as a biological
variable and base
that consideration you may choose to
focus on one sex or to include those
sexes but again you know sex differences
research is not the same thing it's
going to be driven by the questions that
you ask the hypotheses that you ask in
terms of your experimental design now
I'm not again familiar with Huntington's
disease so I don't know the literature I
would do literature search to see if
anybody's even thought about whether or
not there are differences in men versus
women if there's nothing in the
literature that could potentially be a
flag to say hey we'll wait a minute
let's just make sure that if I'm doing
all this work and male animals and the
outcomes and the assumptions that I'm
making will be also relevant to female
animals and eventually to female
patients great thank you we do have
another question do you have suggestions
for using sex or gender and neurological
disorders
I'm not sure I understand the question
that's a very broad question there are
some review articles available and
they're listed at the office of research
for Women's Health website that talks
about tools and strategies when thinking
about sex as a biological variable in
neurological diseases I'm happy to email
that reference or if you go to that
website you can find that reference that
provides some tools and resources and
thinking about neurological diseases
relative to sex and gender great thank
you very much I don't see any other
questions coming in from our audience
right now we're getting close to the end
of our time I'd like to turn it back to
dr. Murphy for any final comments or
thoughts that she has for our audience
today well again my my favorite
conclusion is again the quote from the
institute of medicine report sex and
gender matter from the womb and the tomb
if you think about it what is the first
question we ask when the child is born
is it a boy or a girl and yet we don't
really ask those questions of our
experimental studies did you use male or
female animals so I encourage people
just to put that on their radar and to
think about sex as they would any other
variable when thinking about their
experimental designs
great good information thanks so much
for bringing that to us I want to remind
our audience before we go that this
presentation is approved for continuing
education credits please click on the
free siiii credit button in the bottom
left corner to obtain your credits I
want to thank dr. Murphy again and lab
routes comm for making this web seminar
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
August of 2016 you'll receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay and
we certainly invite you to forward that
email to colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you very much
for joining us see you next time goodbye